monsieur le sénateur vous me posez la
question de l'esprit et de la méthode
que nous allons utiliser pour
progressivement sortir du confinement
pour progressivement faire repartir
notre pays
confiné qu'il est pour des raisons
sanitaires que vous connaissez
parfaitement les d'hier je le redis
aujourd'hui et c'était à d'esprit ne me
quittera pas nous devons être à la fois
prudent et résolu prudent parce que le
déconfinement entre guillemets est un
processus risqués et résolue parce que
ne pas des confiner le seraient au moins
tout autant
nous sommes donc condamnés d'une
certaine façon a avancé prudemment
c'est la raison pour laquelle j'ai
indiqué hier dans mon propos que je
tenais à ce que les opérations de
déconfinement s'effectue progressivement
avec un pas de temps qui permet avant
qu'une nouvelle étape soit franchie de
vérifier que les mesures qui ont été
prises permettent de circonscrire
l'évolution du virus
prudence transparence également d'air
pour dire effectivement quels sont les
résultats des mesures qui ont été prises
c'est le premier aspect le deuxième
aspect que j'évoquais hier c'est celui
d'une forme de différenciation de
territorialisation des mesures pour une
raison qui m'a paraît évidente et qui
j'en suis certain
l'est tout autant dans votre esprit nous
évoquer la question des écoles j'ai
indiqué hier qu'elle était la volonté du
gouvernement permettre la réouverture
progressive des écoles en commençant par
les pré élémentaire et les primaires
puis plus tard dans les zones où cela
est possible les collèges et on verra à
partir de début juin le 31 mai pour le 2
juin ce qu'il en est s'agissant des
lycées
je connais moins le je connais un petit
peu quand même le territoire dans lequel
vous avez été élu je connais bien le
territoire dans lequel j'ai été moi même
élu je connais assez bien les écoles de
la ville dont j'ai été le maire dans
certaines écoles les consignes que nous
avons données pourront être mises en
oeuvre très facilement parce que les
locaux
le taux d'occupation de l'école les
investissements récents font que on
pourra utiliser la totalité des locaux
pour ne pas avoir des classes trop
complète jamais plus de 15 pour
permettre les mesures de distanciation
physique dans toute la mesure du
possible
bref pour que les choses s'organisent au
mieux dans d'autres ce sera plus
difficile
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous avons
plaidé pour cette différenciation pour
faire en sorte que s'agissant des écoles
dans le cadre d'une doctrine général les
maires les directeurs d'école les
représentants de l'état puisse entamer
ce dialogue en confiance et trouver les
meilleures solutions pour que l'école
reprenne
on peut ne pas être d'accord monsieur le
sénateur sur la nécessité que l'école
reprenne mais je vous le dit tout de go
nous voulons que l'école reprenne nous
voulons que les enfants retrouvent le
chemin de l'école et ensuite il nous
faut trouver de bonnes solutions pour
que cela soit possible en faisant
évidemment extrêmement attention à tous
les aspects liés à la sécurité sanitaire
bien entendu mais en faisant en sorte
que ce soit possible et il y aura donc
une discussion locales territoriales
entre les acteurs de terrain qui vont
pouvoir conjuguer leurs efforts pour
faire en sorte que l'objectif qui est
fils et d'en fixer dans cette stratégie
nationale puisse être atteint alors vous
me dites monsieur le sénateur il ya du
flou non y'a une doctrine et ensuite il
va avoir des applications
et si vous voulez me dit me faire dire
que je n'ai pas d'hier ou que je ne
dirais pas aujourd'hui l'ensemble des
détails applicable partout en france
vous avez raison je ne peux pas dire
l'ensemble des détails applicable
partout en france je peux faire état
d'une volonté réouvrir les écoles je
peux faire état de principe
ils ont été fixés et en détails en
détail par le gouvernement
des classes de 15 plusieurs possibilités
offertes
sur ce que pourront faire les élèves et
ensuite je vais faire confiance et au
fond ça ne devrait choquer personne aux
directeurs d'école au maire et au
représentant de l'état monsieur le
sénateur si vous pensez qu'il y à une
autre méthode
une autre méthode pour battre une
épidémie que de faire confiance à ceux
qui sont au plus près du terrain est
capable de prendre des mesures
intelligentes
compte tenu des objectifs qu'on leur
fixe je vous assure monsieur le sénateur
je serais très heureux de l'apprendre je
serais très heureux de pouvoir en
discuter avec vous mais c'est la méthode
que nous avons retenu avec prudence avec
progressivité avec confiance